نبدأ في شرق أوكرانيا حيث
تم تدمير سد كبير في منطقة هاريسون
وسيعقد الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
اجتماعًا طارئًا لمناقشة
الوضع وكما ترون المياه
تتدفق من الخرق تهدد
حياة الآلاف من
المسؤولين الأوكرانيين.  التخطيط لعمليات
الإجلاء وإخبار السكان بالقرب من سد
نوفا كاكوفكا ببذل كل ما في
وسعهم لإنقاذ حياتك في الوقت الحالي ،
يلوم كل من أوكرانيا وروسيا بعضهما البعض
على ما وصفه كلاهما بالهجوم الإرهابي ،
دعنا نطلعك أكثر على هذه
التطورات التي تتكشف
الآن حيث نحن  انضمت إلينا كلير
سيباستيان في لندن أه كلير ، هل نعرف
سبب الاختراق وهل يمكنك
تحديد هذا بالنسبة لنا حيث يوجد السد
بالنسبة إلى الخطوط الأمامية ،
إنه إلى حد كبير في الخطوط الأمامية أه
لاحقًا على حافة دانيبا
نهر على الضفة الجنوبية مباشرة
وتزود تكنولوجيا المعلومات بالمياه لمنطقة هيرسون وشبه جزيرة
القرم المحتلة من قبل روسيا في الجنوب
بالإضافة إلى الطاقة بالطبع من
محطة الطاقة الكهرومائية ، وهي أيضًا تقع
جنوب محطة الطاقة النووية في منطقة السوستة
والتي تعتمد على المياه من مياهها.
خزان للتبريد على الرغم من أن
محطة الطاقة هي الآن في
مراحل مختلفة من الإغلاق ، لذا فقد احتلت روسيا
جزءًا مهمًا جدًا من البنية التحتية
منذ
بداية هذه الحرب.
الآن من أوكرانيا ينظرون فقط إلى
هذه الصور من هذا السد الذي
تم اختراقه وفقًا
للأوكرانيين الذين فعلوا ذلك ، فقد تعرض
لتهديد من كل من
القوات الأوكرانية والروسية لبعض الوقت الآن لدينا الآن
هذا الادعاء بأن الأوكرانيين قد
نفذوا هذا  عملية لخرق
السد مما يؤدي إلى تدفق المياه إلى ما
يُعتقد أنه نهر دونيبو باتجاه
منطقة الساحل ، حسنًا ، فلماذا
يفعلون ذلك ما هي
الميزة العسكرية هنا وهذا نوع من
الدلالة لك على أن هذه بداية
في  جرب هذا
الهجوم الربيعي الذي طال انتظاره من قبل الأوكرانيين لإجبار
الروس على الخروج من أوكرانيا
نعم أعتقد أنه بالتأكيد
مؤشر جون على أن شيئًا مثل هذا
أه تعلمون أن هناك
هجومًا مضادًا أو عملية عسكرية كبيرة
أه تجري بالتأكيد  أه
خرق السد
مثير جدًا لأنك حقًا
تتوقع من الروس أن يفعلوا شيئًا
كهذا لإغراق المنطقة بحيث
يكون من الصعب جدًا على
الأوكرانيين عبور نهر الزنوج في
المناطق الواقعة أسفل السد أه و  في
اتجاه مجرى النهر من السد أه لذا أه
تعلم أن هذا شيء
يصبح ممتعًا للغاية لأنه
سيكون من الصعب على الأوكرانيين
أن يفعلوا أه ما يجب عليهم فعله
ولكن سيكون من الصعب أيضًا على
الروس أه نقلهم
دعنا نقول أه أجزاء من
منطقة كارسون قد أخلوها في
الخريف ، لذا أعتقد أن هذا سيكون
تطورًا مهمًا للغاية
ويمكن أن يؤثر أيضًا بشكل كبير على
البنية التحتية المدنية في المنطقة ، كانت هناك
بعض التكهنات بأن الأوكرانيين
يمكنهم  افعل هذا ثم تابع مع
المركبات كجزء من هذا الهجوم ،
والذي من شأنه أن يجعل الأمر منطقيًا
إلى حد ما ، أليس كذلك إلى حد ما لأنني ربما
قاموا بقياس الأشياء
بحيث أه يجب عليك  أعلم أنه سيكون
منطقيًا من
وجهة نظر مركبة برمائية أه أن يكون لديك سطح مائي كافٍ
للمرور والقيام بالأشياء
بهذه الطريقة ، لذا
ربما كان هذا جزءًا من الحسابات التي
تعرفها من قبل المهندسين الأوكرانيين
للقيام بذلك إذا كان ذلك بالفعل  هو ما
حدث هنا